dix ans après charles trenet était à
nouveau hier soir à la fiche du
printemps de bourges des vedettes
d'aujourd'hui ont interprété ses
chansons et lui-même a fait un véritable
triomphe dans son propre récit tanisha
diane le moment même où les béruriers
noirs se préparait dans le délire et la
provocation un récital qui n'en manqua
pas non plus enfant rebelle dans les
textes carré martel tout ce qui fait mal
au coeur
charles trenet se paye est peut-être le
plus beau traque de sa route enchantée
avant d'affronter un public qui lui
était pourtant acquis d'avancé aux
france 50 ans après ses débuts le fou
chantant n'at-il pas garder cette
insolence cette liberté de ton qui le
rapproche des béruriers noirs et autres
jeunes chanteurs d'aujourd'hui n'est ce
pas son anticonformisme définitif qui a
défié les modes qui a sécrété ce charme
persistant en une multitude d'instants
privilégiés de grâce à des motions
commis hier soir à bourges les boutiques
pop lady d'honneur 3e trail ou
bonjour
aujourd'hui la paix
c'est gentil la mode impasse qui dure
c'est là
la vérité et la sincérité
la sincérité que sa vie les clubs
eux-mêmes être en bio déçu avec nos
trois pourtant comme en rêve
gagné a permis de faire une chanson
chanson attend en ce n'est que l'amour
chance en vain
je suis malheureux comme tout le monde
je les cache avec plus ou moins de
bonheur
je cache pour malheur avec du bonheur
soleil mer
m
10e arraché par m
une seule de vos chansons sifflé dans la
rue suffira-t-elle à justifier notre
route enchantée
ah oui ça fait toujours plaisir dans le
jour j ai entendu et romance barry joué
par un vieux manège sous la tour eiffel
il y avait que les petits-enfants si
charmant oui